all right the thor love and thunder
trailer is here we've got storm breaker
mule near ready to go we've waited long
enough to watch it so let's go ahead and
watch it
these hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
who i am
[Music]
he's getting in shape
[Music]
[Applause]
memories
[Music]
zeus
russell crowe
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh the mighty thor she looks awesome
oh i'm gonna go back to that
oh that looks awesome
wow
okay well that was very much a teaser
trailer uh that's a super cool pose
right there
that was very much a teaser trailer we
didn't see gore but we saw zeus we saw
the guardians of the galaxy ravager thor
new asgard uh we saw valkyrie would she
appeared to be kind of dealing with
human things which is something that
she's probably definitely not used to um
it didn't look like we saw much of earth
i'm not sure
um
how many of those scenes took place on
earth but it looks like this is going to
be like a thor slash guardians of the
galaxy movie looks like they're going to
be in a lot of the movie and maybe thor
will be in guardians of the galaxy 3 as
well which i'm really excited for but
first look at natalie portman as the
mighty thor she looks awesome um
can't wait to see gore we didn't see
christian bell it always saw the back of
russell crowe that was definitely zeus
with the lightning that looked like it
was olympia um i definitely think the
trailer was worth the wait it was very
much a taika tt guardians of the galaxy
trailer a good combination of thor and
guardians of the galaxy i think and
overall i think there's an awesome
trailer let me know what you thought
about it in the comments down below i'm
gonna do my breakdown right now so
expect that in a couple hours and yeah
first look i loved it let me know what
you think don't forget to like the video
and don't forget to subscribe and go do
my breakdown i'll see you guys wolf wolf